historian Lonnie bunch is the first
african-american to serve as head of the
one hundred and seventy three-year-old
Smithsonian Institution he's in charge
of 19 museums 21 libraries and the
National Zoo and he oversees about 7,000
employees in all Bunch is also founding
director of the National Museum of
african-american history and culture in
Washington DC
it is welcome more than six million
visitors since opening in 2016
bunch writes about his journey
establishing the museum in his new book
a fool's errand creating the National
Museum of african-american history and
culture in the age of Bush Obama and
Trump and he joins us at the table
good morning also a very successful
museum yeah so why is it a fool's errand
given where it ended up because when I
started everybody told me it was foolish
to take this on because it started with
no staff no idea where the museum would
be no collections no money people told
me you should be the second director
because the first one you called it the
museum of no in the beginning should get
so many knows it good no it was just
amazing to me that how many people
really didn't believe what happened this
is never going to work but I also like
Lonnie from the very beginning it wasn't
a FUBU moment for you where it's for us
by us you said this is not a museum for
black people by black people this is a
quintessential American story and I
think that's so important what's the
point you're making my point is that
often we look at african-american
history as an ancillary story but yet if
you want to understand American core
values of spirit truth reality
resiliency optimism it's the
african-american story so I want people
to realize this is their story
regardless of who they are but you were
told you were stuck first let's say lots
of people had lots of ideas about what
should be in the museum
did they not absolutely not be in what
should not and you were stopped by an
older black woman who said whatever you
do don't talk about slavery that's right
she was a church lady walking from
church and I was walking and she said
whatever you do I love what you're doing
but if you talk about slavery you're
gonna hurt the community
yeah I thought what and I thought if
slavery was the number one thing people
didn't want to know about it was the
number one thing I had to let people
know because it was the quintus
central bases of America and I thought
that in some ways we're still dealing
with the legacy of slavery so I wanted
people to understand how important that
institution was you had a battle
building this collection and one of the
stories I love is is is a conversation
you ended up having with Chuck Berry you
wanted his guitar he wanted you to have
his car exactly so Chuck Berry we call
him I want the guitar Lee wrote
Maybelline and all of that and so he
said I'm only gonna give you the guitar
if you take my candy apple red Cadillac
I don't want this Cadillac turned out to
be a big attract the staff loved it
people loved it it's the number one
thing people take pictures of in the
museum but he didn't he didn't trust you
in the beginning he started yelling on
the phone the next day they didn't trust
me because as he put it I just found out
you work for the federal government
donation might be a good tax write-off
exactly but now you've got 40,000
artifacts most of them came from
people's basement and garages I think
the the collection that you did to get
this museum in place I think is
astounding work you and your staff start
out with the staff of two what you and
Tasha Coleman did well I think the the
thing for me was I knew that we couldn't
just have technology because of the
Smithsonian you have the Greensboro
lunch counted the ruby slippers the
Wright Flyer so I said we had to find
good stuff so I one day I fell asleep
and I woke up in front of the television
and there was anti Groucho you know and
I thought what a good idea so I put a
spin on it
well it's saving African American
treasures and we went around the country
and said bring out your stuff and 70
percent of all the things we found in
the collection came from basements
trunks and attics of people I love we
said at the top this is a very popular
museum you got a call from somebody
alleging to be your seventh-grade
girlfriend what owning tickets what I
love is everybody wants tickets no
matter where I go right and so I got
this call and this woman said she wanted
tickets and I said I don't do tickets
and she said I don't think you're my
girlfriend but she said she was my
seventh-grade girlfriend she said the
name and I'm thinking when you're 13 you
remember every crush you had so I didn't
know her at all but did you give her the
ticket it was such a good like ever the
ticket
bunny buds thanks so much fool's errand
is on sale now